[Musique]
bonjour a tous rêvé de vous retrouver
bonjour chez vous à l'heure de la
présidentielle nous vous proposons une
série d'émissions spéciales nous
recevons les candidats avec les
journalistes de la presse quotidienne
régionale et aujourd'hui notre invité
yannick jadot bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation êtes le candidat écologiste à
cette élection présidentielle
nous sommes ensemble pendant une heure
et avec les journalistes de la presse
régionale nous interrogeons sur les
thèmes qui font partie des
préoccupations majeures des français de
leur quotidien on parlera des déserts
médicaux de la hausse des prix du
pouvoir d'achat de l'écologie de
l'agriculture ou encore de la fracture
territoriale et services publics et de
cette france qui se sont oubliés vous
nous direz ce que vous lui dites ce
matin à cette france là et pour vous
interroger six journalistes de la presse
régionale sur ce plateau florent buisson
de la république du centre le groupe
centre-france bonjour laurent bonjour
jefferson des sports de sud-ouest
bonjour jefferson bonjour union bouchons
et yannick jadot est avec nous depuis
leurs rédactions locales on retrouve
roger antech de corse matin qui se
trouve à ajaccio bonjour roger holliger
claudon des dernières nouvelles d'alsace
qui lui est à strasbourg bonjour olivier
chrismaëlle marchante de la presse de la
manche qui se trouve à cherbourg et
enfin eric berger de la dépêche du midi
qui se trouve lui à toulouse bonjour
monsieur à tout à l'heure évidemment
yannick jadot on commence par l'ukraine
emmanuel macron s'est de nouveau
entretenu hier pendant une heure et
demie avec vladimir poutine qui reste
déterminée a dit le chef de l'état
emmanuel mac on dit que le pire est à
venir après son entretien avec vladimir
poutine et cette nuit des frappes russes
ont touché la centrale nucléaire de
zappos ridja c'est la plus grande
centrale nucléaire d'europe on est dans
une escalade est-ce qu'on peut encore
arrêté vladimir poutine et comment il
faut se donner tous les moyens il faut
se donner tous les moyens parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il n'ya plus de limites
pour vladimir poutine on savait sa
volonté d'annihiler
l'ukraine comme pays autonome comme pays
indépendant comme pays démocratiques
parce que ça reste le grand problème de
vladimir poutine la démocratie dans son
pays et dans son voisinage
on avait déjà
d'immenses inquiétude quand tu les
combats autour de tchernobyl
et puis maintenant il n'hésite pas à
envoyer le signal qu'il pourrait
attaquer la plus grande centrale
nucléaire d'europe vous l'avez mentionné
avec les dommages majeurs qui pourrait y
avoir partout donc l'europe pour
l'instant et c'est très bien elle est
unie elle est très ferme très très ferme
c'est comme ça qu'on construit un
rapport de force très vite vladimir
poutine qu'on met en danger y compris sa
légitimité interne
exclusion totale de la communauté
internationale il faut continuer
sanctions massives il faut traquer les
fortunes et les oligarques partout dans
le monde partout dans les paradis
fiscaux
il faut évidemment
protéger les ukrainiennes et les
ukrainiens ceux qui se battent
aujourd'hui dans les rues dans les
maisons
sur les routes ce qu'il fallait redonner
de dialoguer avec il faut continuer il
faut qu'ils aient toujours un canal de
négociation possible - vous savez j'ai
toujours souhaité que ce soit l'union
européenne qui se met en situation de
dialoguer pour un chien cessez-le-feu
c'est ce que vous direz manuel macron
tout seul dit lassé ça dans l'union
européenne oui bien sûr je dis pas qu'il
n'a pas la légitimité d'être là
évidemment mais vous avez vu dans les
dents les dernières semaines cette
diplomatie qui vise à voir seuls
vladimir poutine à le tutoyer alors que
vladimir poutine est quand même un
dictateur
bien sûr on n'est pas ami avec vladimir
poutine on n'est pas ami avec quelqu'un
qui a rasé grozny cam massacrer les
tchétchènes qui a bombardé des
populations civiles en syrie qu'à
attaquer la géorgie camille des
dictateurs en biélorussie qui eux
tu es encore une fois l'identique
l'identité même dû peuple ukrainien et
on sait tous ce qui fait dans en
empoisonnant ses adversaires ses
opposants on clique on file on se la
séance terminée ils ont un réseau sortir
de ça il y avait de la part du président
république une grande naïveté au mieux
une grande arrogance sinon il faut que
ce soit l'union européenne qui tente le
rapport de force personne ne dit que
c'est simple parce qu'on voit bien
interrogateurs cela van doren ou non il
faut que ce soit évidemment le président
de la république il est président de
l'union européenne c'est important il
faut qu'ils charles michel le président
du conseil il faut qu'ils y est pour
cela venu vers l'ailleurs bien sûr et
puis ça me fout là emmanuel il faut
étudier et obi olaf scholz et d'autres
dirigeants européens il ya on est on
n'est pas amis éleveurs lumière poutine
on joue pas je te tutoie donc je vais me
convaincre et ça va bien se passer la
réalité de la dernière poutine ça n'est
pas celle là donc il faut imposer le
maximum de sanctions soutenir la
résistance ukrainien justement il
continuer sur cette question de soutenir
la résistance ukrainien de vous aide
pour les livraisons d'armes de la france
a gelé avait dès le début mais par
contre dès le 24 ans aussi est ce que là
est tendu et qui est un caractère
stratégique est ce que vous ne
fragiliser pas la position française en
demandant cette transparence parce que
c'est aussi un argument de plus pour
voler le mignan poutine pour continuer
sa défiance non enfin là
le gouvernement
explique le type de livraisons d'armes
qu'on a visé en défensive vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et craignent un l'expliqua
aux députés à l'assemblée nationale dans
le cadre de commissions c'est déjà un
exercice de transparence
tous les pays européens ont affiché la
volonté de fournir des armes défensives
la transparence est pas de donner notre
bon de livraison à vladimir poutine vous
avez raison notre transparence et
d'expliquer aux françaises et aux
français par exemple ce que sont des
armes de défense avec les françaises et
les français sont extrêmement inquiet de
la situation évidemment comme tout le
monde ils ressentent bien que c'est la
paix la sécurité la démocratie qui sont
attaqués sur l'ensemble du continent
européen que c'est un conflit qu'on a
pas vu depuis des décennies donc c'est
la nécessité de de prendre le temps
d'expliquer aux françaises et aux
français ce qui se passe ce qui se passe
évidemment en quoi ça nous concerne très
immédiatement je les dis p sécurité
démocratie en quoi ça nous concerne 13
immédiatement et peut-être durablement
sur certains secteurs économiques sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français parce que
voilà dans ces moments de tension dans
ces moments d'angoissé il faut il faut
aussi prendre le temps de de dire les
choses aux français on verra sur le
pouvoir d'achat mais je reste sur les
questions de défense la faveur de cette
crise eu que cette guerre en ukraine est
ce que vous le candidat yannick jadot
vous êtes prêt si vous êtes élus à
soutenir l'industrie de défense en tout
cas la défense française à l'arrêt armée
à poursuivre les investissements y
compris sur la dissuasion nucléaire
on voit que la dissuasion nucléaire est
un sujet qu'il faut
traiter avec beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de vigilance sachant que ça vous a pas
échappé à bondy ça vous a pas échappé
que vladimir poutine a brandi cette
menace qui dit bien à quel point
la limite poutine est un dirigeant
dangereux aujourd'hui ce qui dit aussi
parce que quand on brandit la dissuasion
nucléaire ou la menace nucléaire ça veut
dire que les intérêts vitaux du pays
sont engagés qu'est ce que ça dit ça dit
qu'en fait il fait de l'ukraine une
question interne on s'est dit ce qu'il
veut faire de l'ukraine
mais ça nous rappelle à quel point les
processus de désarmement nucléaire qui
ont été engagées dans le cadre du traité
de non-prolifération que tous les pays
dotés ont signé doit doit ce processus
là doit reprendre il a été stoppé
notamment par trump
avec la fin septembre d'accord avec vous
aussi vous dites quoi vous les
initiateurs nucléaire la française et
dont le club des puissances nucléaires
faudra la question n'est pas le
désarmement unilatéral
certainement pas aujourd'hui mais de
reprendre des initiatives multilatérales
de désarmement nucléaire parce qu'on a
des pays dotés il faut réduire les
arsenal et puis les arsenaux pardon et
puis il ya des pays qui veulent acquérir
et des groupes terroristes qui peuvent
acquérir la bombe donc la question de la
prolifération dans un monde aussi
instable reste une question majeure dont
il se
comportera des initiatives de
désarmement y compris fo à le faire à
l'initiative de la france et de la
grande-bretagne par exemple yannick
jadot emmanuel macron officialisé sa
candidature à la présidentielle ce n'est
pas vraiment une surprise signé ce matin
une lettre dans la presse régionale
c'est une lettre qui est à la hauteur
des enjeux pour vous écouter ce que
propose emmanuel macron c'est le même
quinquennat en pire
c'est au fond vous interpréter cette
lettre ah ben oui si vous voulez moi je
vois les dossiers qu'est ce qui nous dit
au fond
en 2017 il dit je veux vos suffrages et
ma promesse c'est qu'on va revenir sur
les rentes on va combattre les lobbys on
va sortir du conformisme on va remettre
les corps intermédiaires au coeur de la
démocratie on va lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
on y va y avoir de l'agilité de la
mobilité sociale après cinq ans on a les
riches qui sont plus riches les pauvres
qui sont plus pauvres plus d'inégalités
on a des fractures territoriales comme
on n'a jamais connu dans notre pays un
président condamné deux fois par les
tribunaux pour inaction climatique la
france le seul pays européen qui n'a pas
respecté ses objectifs en matière
d'énergies renouvelables il fait aussi
j'ai fait hier la coupe a quand même
oui enfin nous n'avons ici il est des
choix qui à ma ba c'est bien ça qui est
en fait c'est nous qui avons pas réussi
c'est pas lui en fallait qu'on sorte de
mea culpa au nom
la blague des mea culpa la télé vous
souvenez il fait son émission du genre
sur tf1 l'émission publi reportage qui
avait été fait et il nous dit les choses
que j'aurais pu dire et hagarde les
français dans les yeux mesdames
messieurs un peu voyez georges prends
sur moi je baisse un peu la tête et le
lendemain il dit que les non vaccinés
sont pas des citoyens et qu' il veut les
emmerder donc c'est un comédien emmanuel
macron pour vous bien sûr bien sûr mais
il a une responsabilité aujourd'hui les
présidents de la république mais ce qui
est certain c'est que au regard du défi
climatique au regard des enjeux de
diversité des cultures on y viendra me
laverai jamais il avait payé en salant
sur le plan écologique pour vous il ya
quand il ya quand même des choses qui
ont été à coire ya quand même une la
prime à la casse il ya quand même des
thermes et tissement pour rénover les
bâtiments attendu si vous regardez c'est
pour le climat
ah oui alors là on a eu un truc qui est
l'abandon de notre dame des landes ce
projet que tout le monde savait qu'il
était pas possible donc ça ça reste le
bilan écologique du président de la
république d'abandonner un projet qui
pouvait plus se faire tant mieux moi
j'applaudis quand il a abandonné j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi françois
hollande n'est pas pris cette décision
ce qui montrent que vaut mieux des
écologistes pour gouverner mais
sur la rénovation thermique je veux dire
on n'a jamais fait aussi peu de
rénovation globale cm2 de vraie
rénovation de nos logements alors que on
sait que le vrai bouclier énergétique
pour les françaises et les français la
vraie le vrai soutien en matière de
pouvoir d'achat c'est de combattre les
dépenses contraintes et la dépense de
chauffage et d'électricité est une
dépense majeure et donc on a réduit nos
investissements sur les rénovation
profonde des rénovations globales je les
dis on est le seul pays européen qui
seul pays européen qui n'a pas respecté
ses objectifs en matière d'énergies
renouvelables il a il a reculé sur le
glyphosate sur les néonicotinoïdes on
pourrait pas et l'achat sont pour elle
et par elle qu'un chose non ça a été un
président des lobbys
enfin sous les 6 6 puis avoir une image
de bilan y compris dans le contexte
actuel c'est en 2018 emmanuel macron il
est à saint pétersbourg avec vladimir
poutine son ami vladimir poutine est ici
une deux contrats et tout ça est mis en
scène comme il sait le faire il signe de
contrat total pour le gaz qu'on a
toujours pas sorti c'est à dire que
c'est un contrat appuyé par le président
de république maintenant on nous
explique que total sait ce qu'il veut et
il signe au rhdp à total et le
développement d'orpea les ehpad dont on
a vu des scandales machin est bien ça
pour moi ça résume son le bilan de ce
quinquennat le gaz
et la spéculation sur nos aînés et une
complaisance de wingineer poutine et une
dernière question là-dessus jefferson
après on va on va à cherbourg simplement
sur cette lettre est ce que vous
attendiez maintenant un débat clair avec
moi il maintenant oui oui il faut
absolument qu'il y ait un débat
digne de ce nom dans ce pays on a eu
la pandémie avant la pandémie mulet
gilet jaune
qui racontait quand même
l'éclatement de l'aménagement du
territoire ça raconte et vous savez ce
qu'on appelle la diagonale du vide c'est
tous ces territoires ya plus de services
publics où il ya peu d'activités
économiques ou du coup c'est la cohésion
se délite ont trait plus vraiment
société
les gens sont en difficultés lourdes ont
parlé des contraintes de dépenses les
comptes les mobilités contraintes bref
y'a les gilet jaune il ya eu la pandémie
qui a dit à quel point le quinquennat
macron le quinquennat hollande et le
caquet mais sarkozy avait été dès qu un
keynote d'abandon de l'hôpital public
donc il fallait
tout ça pour dire quoi que
il ya beaucoup de colère dans notre pays
il ya beaucoup d'angoissé d'inquiétude
il ya aussi beaucoup d'énergie
d'enthousiasmé mais si le débat de
l'élection présidentielle est tronqué
ses colères ses angoisses ses peurs et
ses enthousiasmes ne trouveront pas de
débouché politique et il faut absolument
si on veut réconcilier notre pays si on
veut l'apaiser et le redonner une
perspective il faut qu'on ait un débat
politique sérieux et on va parler des
questions d'énergie mal à cherbourg pour
ça on retrouve chrismaëlle marchand
bonjour chris neil merci beaucoup je
vois pas bien le lien entre cherbourg et
les questions d'énergie
pour m'expliquer ovale et la presse de
la branche à des questions sur le
nucléaire sur les éoliennes geste la
parole à chrismaëlle
respectivement dans la manche et plus
précisément à cherbourg et dans le
cotentin on nous vivons n'est pas sans
le savoir monsieur jadot sur un
territoire portée
aller chez vous r on y trouve des
entreprises comme nava groupe et c'est
une sous marin nucléaire aura nos et son
usine de retraitement mais aussi edf à
flamanville et ses deux réacteurs est
normalement bientôt trois je parle
évidemment de le père ce réacteur de 3e
génération qui alimente la chronique
depuis des années alors il a été lancé
en 2007 il devait être mis en service en
2012 on est en 2022 donc dix ans plus
tard il ne fonctionne toujours pas autre
anomalie défaut --même dessert c'est un
chantier qui est un énorme caillou dans
la chaussure d'edf
c'est aussi une fuite une fuite en avant
budgétaire puisque son coût est passé de
3,3 milliards à 12,7 milliards d'euros
et même 19 selon la cour des comptes
alors là à l'heure actuelle le père ne
devrait pas fournir d'électricité avant
mi 2000 2023 si tout se passe bien dès
lors ma question est simple monsieur
jeannot si vous êtes élu président dans
quelques semaines alors notre
indépendance énergétique est une
question centrale à lors du conflit en
ukraine déciderez-vous de ne pas
démarrer ce secteur et de tirer un trait
sur tous ces milliards investis
alors vous avez eu raison de dire à quel
point le père de flamanville était un
fiasco absolu
vous dit qu'ils pourraient être mis en
service mi 2023 on peut toujours
avoir la foi et la fois nucléaire est
une fois très très forte très dur vous
savez que y compris si le père devait
être mis en service à cette date là
c'est pour quelques mois puisqu'on doit
changer le couvercle du réacteur puisque
ce couvercle a aussi des défauts donc au
fond la facture va être de plus de 20
milliards et probablement c'est pas
le pnr entre art aux parents service il
n'est jamais entré en service avant des
années
c'est quand même extraordinaire donc moi
qu'est ce que je fais je fais un audit
très sérieux de l'état de ce chantier et
des risques il vous a pas échappé que
les au père qui fonctionne ou qui ont
fonctionné en chine appelle aujourd'hui
à tirer des leçons y compris du
fonctionnement du réacteur puisque les
ep en chine ont été arrêtés au début on
nous a expliqué que c'était simplement
un problème de combustible il pourrait
s'avérer il pourrait s'avérer parce
qu'évidemment la transparence n'existe
pas sérieusement que c'est un problème
aux fondus du réacteur de vibrations du
réacteur
donc on à moi ce que je veux faire c'est
un audit très précis de l'état de ce
chantier d'avoir une commission
parlementaire qui étudie cet audit est
sur cette base là on regarde si on
poursuit ce chantier où on le stop mais
vous avez raison de dire que il ya eu 17
milliards d'euros à ce jour de gabegie
de surcoûts sans qu'il n'y ait jamais eu
une enquête et malgré tout c'est près
l'arrêter si jamais je dis qu on fait un
audit pour savoir si ce réacteur doit
fonctionner ou pas il faut quand même
présent à vt à cette dit aux
parlementaires et aux parlementaires
pour trancher la question les le dessin
si vous acceptez vous en faites quoi
parce que si la crise la question c'est
pas si je l'art est j'en fais quoi c'est
si je démarre il se passe quoi c'est ça
le sujet c'est si je démarre il se passe
quoi est ce qui importe de compétences
yannick jadot pour construire sa
aujourd'hui parce que c'était aussi
efficace et qui est la réplique veut
relancer le nucléaire oui alors c'est
sûr des compétences et poser un question
compétences pour ma part moi je suis
favorable à recruter des ingénieurs des
techniciens des ouvriers dans le
nucléaire
aujourd'hui on a une perte de
compétences si vous voyez les rapports
sur la multiplication des arrêts
non prévus des réacteurs il y a
des problèmes de sûreté il ya des
problèmes de vieillissement il ya aussi
des problèmes d'erreur humaine et donc
il faut absolument pas lié la la la la
réduction des compétences donc il faut
et vous savez quel est mon projet alors
on passe un peu on voyage un peu mais
donc sur le projet e p r audit décision
sur l'état du réacteur et sa capacité le
truc mais on est quand même dans un truc
est totalement dingue vous avez un ep
dont vous avez parfaitement expliquer le
fiasco financier et industriel et vous
avez un président de la république qui
dit vous avez des problèmes de factures
d'énergie aujourd'hui on a un problème
de climat aujourd'hui je vous propose de
multiplier par 6 8 14 un fiasco
aujourd'hui pour avoir des ep en 2040
2045 tout ça c'est du bricolage absolue
lui dit que l'asie la garantie notre
indépendance énergie de la corse vous
savez d'où vient d' uranium à l'étranger
non non il vient pas de l'étranger
madame il vient de l'étranger il y ait
deux sets à rien pas de l'étranger il
faut quand même lit que les françaises
et les français le sachent ça vient du
kazakhstan sous tutelle russe ça vient
de l'ouzbékistan sous tutelle russe ça
vient du niger
pays aujourd'hui assez instable donc
j'allais dire humeau rien à votre
calendrier de sortie du nucléaire mon
calendrier c'est une dizaine de raids
calendrier c'est de voir sa vie il ya
une loi en france en fait en 2015 et
noah s'appelle la loi transition
énergétique il ya eu un grand débat
public dans notre pays il ya une loi à
l'assemblée nationale
et ça a concerné les pro nucléaires les
antinucléaires les pros renouvelable
tout le monde a participé tout le monde
a élaboré cette loi emmanuel macron une
fois de plus il sait que cette chose ici
dans ses passes et chris hager
démocratie il s'assoit dessus donc un on
investit massivement sur les économies
d'énergie c'est le meilleur service à
rendre aux français pour leur pouvoir
d'achat pour leur confort la canicule
les machins ont réduit les impôts et
juste 2 on déploie les énergies
renouvelables et au fur à mesure qu'on
n'a plus besoin des réacteurs nucléaires
on les ferme moi je veux pas si j'arrive
les français le décide j'arrive au
pouvoir je ne construis pas les
réacteurs pour 2045 mais je ne ferme pas
de réacteurs nucléaires je déploie les
énergies renouvelables et
progressivement on arrêtera les
réacteurs nucléaires les plus
dangereuses
justement crise mais là des questions
sur les éoliennes
on change d'énergie effectivement qui de
du côté de l'autre bord du cotentin sont
en projet les deux plus grands parcs
éoliens en mer français notamment située
en face des tours de tatihou de la
hougue qui sont inscrits au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco il cristallise
l'opposition de nombreux riverains et
pêcheurs c'est souvent le cas pour ce
genre de projet alors dans ce contexte
tendu et dans un domaine où la france
est en retard on peut le dire est ce que
ces parcs géants comme la tour eiffel
sont ils sur la meilleure solution pour
accélérer la transition énergétique
alors au comme la tour eiffel si vous
prenez le haut de la page oui enfin mais
c'est important c'est important parce qu
en fait
oui très clairement oui vous savez il ya
cinq mille quatre cents éoliennes
offshore en mer du nord 5400 chez nos
voisins on a même les belges on a
plusieurs centaines chez les
britanniques on est à près de 2000
ça se passe bien et que les pêcheurs à
un moment donné il faut choisir on a la
guerre en ukraine on la voit
les combats sur tchernobyl la centrale
nucléaire
la plus grosse centrale nucléaire qui
est menacée on a ces fiascos et les
parcs éoliens dans vous parler notamment
on pourrait parler celui de dunkerque
qui va se développer c'est un prix de
sortie d'électricité deux fois moins
cher que le p r et c'est beaucoup plus
d'emplois sur nos territoires donc la
vraie les vraies énergies de paix de
sécurité les vraies énergies qui nous
évite les dépendances et les
complaisances politique insupportable
qu'on a vu vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine
ce sont des énergies renouvelables alors
à un moment donné c'est vrai il faut
assumer il ya une partie de pollution
vous avez vous produisez de
l'électricité sur votre territoire il ya
toujours une pollution ça peut être une
pollution visuelle ça peut être voilà
mais à un moment donné faut choisir est
ce qu'on veut le gaz russe est ce qu'on
veut le pétrole du golfe est-ce qu'on
veut le pétrole de total qui va dévaster
des pays africains entier en exploitant
le pétrole où on assume notre part de
responsabilité et on gère avec les
populations on gère avec les secteurs
économiques la satisfaction de nos
besoins d'électricité on peut remercier
chris neil marchand merci chris neil
d'avoir été avec nous pour ces vers sont
pas passés au pouvoir d'achat feront
yannick jadot vous vous dites défenseur
d'une écologie qui rend du pouvoir
d'achat comment vous faites cela alors
que l'essence atteint des records que
les produits du quotidien qui ne sont
pas tous dangereux pour la planète sont
en hausse de 3 à 4% comment vous faites
concrètement demain en tout cas dans un
mois et demi si vous êtes élu 1 sadi le
manque d'anticipation des gouvernements
précédents c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya une crise ça c'est dans mes
bouquins mais c'est important c'est
important parce que si vous voulez ceux
qui se revendiquent aujourd'hui les
alliés du pouvoir d'achat sont aussi
ceux qui ont gouverné et ont mis les
français aussi vulnérable par rapport
aux crises internationales par rapport à
leurs revenus donc un première chose le
poids d'achat au fond il ya ce qu'on
touche en revenus et il ya ce qu'on paye
en dépenses
ce qu'on touche en revenus vous savez
moi je vais augmenter dès l'arrivée au
pouvoir le smic à 1400 euros net
augmenter les 500 dans le programme
diffusant ses 1500 sur le quinquennat
a dès l'arrivée 1400
on augmente les bas salaires on impose
des négociations sur les bas salaires
dans toutes les filières qui ont été
particulièrement
indispensable pendant
la crise du coc vide et dont on a vu que
ces métiers étaient souvent un
visibiliser et que ce gouvernement a
rendu à ma gratitude sociale donc on
augmente les salaires évidemment dans la
fonction publique dans les services
publics bon sens on y reviendra
peut-être pareille manière après c'est
la spécificité du projet écologiste
c'est d'agir sur les dépenses
contraintes c'est quoi les dépenses
contraintes vous l'avez dit c'est le
logement
contrairement à ce qui a été fait dans
ce quinquennat nous allons construire
700 mille logements sociaux sur le
quinquennat prochain c'est vous avez 2
millions de familles en france qu
attendent un logement social c'est la
première dépense donc on construit du
logement social pour réduire le coût du
logement on met 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissements par an sur les
économies d'énergie c'est 600 700 euros
d'économisés par an pour les ménages et
vous avez 12 millions de français qui
ont froid cet hiver et qui vont
probablement avoir très chaud cet été si
les météorologues ne se plante pas sur
la canicule qui s'annonce on investit
sur les transports collectifs qu'on
était le parent pauvre encore de ce
quinquennat et du quinquennat précédent
pour réduire les coûts dans mon projet
je veux que les entreprises mettent en
place qui existe dans la loi mais qui
est optionnel c'est le forfait mobilité
durable et par exemple je veux rendre
gratuit le covoiturage pour les français
qui n'ont pas accès des transports
collectifs et qu'ils peuvent s'organiser
plutôt que de dépenser 2000 euros par an
par exemple si vous faites 30 bornes
pour aller de votre domicile par jour au
boulot salue 2000 euros en prenant en
faisant
saucier qui n'ont pas de choix yannick
femmes qui sont obligées
je vous dis je suis ce que je fais on y
voit le litre d'eau traitée qui va je
sais à 2 euros est ce que vous jouez
vous aider à payer la ruine je vous dis
toutes les réformes structurelles que
j'engage pour que ces dépenses
contraintes baisse
en arrivant on met immédiatement en
place un chèque énergie de 400 euros
pour les six millions de familles qui en
bénéficient déjà et 200 euros pour les
15 millions de familles au dessus donc
la mesure d'urgence absolue c'est ce
chèque énergie pour compenser la hausse
des carburants et qui revient vous êtes
prêts à baisser les taxes non parce que
je pense que si vous voulez baisser les
taxes vous donner un chèque mais vous
laisser le prix de l'essence a flambé
oui parce que je pense que ça va faire
la question moi je compensais pour les
familles pour lesquelles le coût est le
plus élevé si vous voulez entre une
infirmière qui fait 50 km par jour
dans une clio et la personne qui a
beaucoup d'argent et qui a un gros 4 4
je suis désolé moi je compense d'abord
l'infirmière avant le gros 4 4 c'est un
choix politique parce qu'en fait baisser
la tva ça profitera d'abord à ceux qui
ont les plus gros moteur qu ont les plus
grosses voitures et bien c'est pas ma
vision de la justice sociale est très
très cher pour l'exhorter à
c'est tous les ans c'est tous les ans
donc 100 euros par an mais si vous avez
le mariage a enchaîné six ans après tout
ça coûtera beaucoup moins cher ça
coûtera beaucoup moins cher que les
mesures qui sont prises à coutras moyen
du monde va à bastille où les 400 euros
pour 6 millions de familles ça fait plus
de dix ans allez on va parler
d'agriculture maintenant yannick jadot
on va à toulouse on retrouve eric berger
bonjour eric merci d'être avec nous un
acteur en chef adjoint de la dépêche du
midi et vous avez une question brian et
jada sur l'agriculture oui bonjour
yannick jadot la région occitanie
d'ailleurs et la première aux régions
agricoles
de france en nombre d'exploitations et
de terres agricoles je crois que vous
êtes rendus sur le salon hier c'est vrai
que le salon donne une image très
positive de la profession toutefois
derrière ces images il ya une réalité
c'est que quand même beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui ont des difficultés
financières un taux de pauvreté qui est
d'ailleurs très élevé dans cette
profession et puis chaque année on perd
c'est pas un problème spécifique à notre
région mais on perd des exploitations je
crois qu'il y en a cent mille qui ont
disparu ces dix dernières années alors
très concrètement qu'est ce que vous
proposez pour aider les agriculteurs à
vivre décemment de leur métier et puis
aussi pour aider les jeunes à
s'installer comment faire pour pour les
inciter à reprendre des exploitations
vous avez parfaitement raison vous avez
posé les deux grands sujets les revenus
des agriculteurs la question de
l'installation des jeunes et on aurait
pu ajouter y compris dans ce contexte la
question de souveraineté alimentaire
on va en parler très bien
aujourd'hui dans notre pays on met tous
les ans à peu près 13 milliards d'euros
d'argent public dans l'agriculture en
aide directe à l'agriculture c'est
considérable dont 9 milliards qui
viennent de l'union européenne et vous
l'avez souligné on a 40 % des
agriculteurs qui vivent avec moins de
350 euros par mois donc une énorme
précarisation on a près d'un suicide par
jour
27 ferme par jour qui disparaissent et
la biodiversité qui s'effondrent
des problèmes de mal bouffe un peu
partout très dur pour les pour les
jeunes aujourd'hui et des campagnes qui
se désertifient donc le bilan de la
politique publique de l'écriture est une
catastrophe est une catastrophe donc il
faut en changer ce que je propose c'est
moi avec ses 13 milliards d'avoirs
impact de transformation de
l'agriculture avec le monde agricole
c'est à dire qu'en fait on va
accompagner les agriculteurs pour
changer de modèle et on arrête
d'agrandir les fermes où les aider les
agriculteurs sont toujours plus seuls
dans des fermes toujours plus grande où
ils sont toujours plus endettés on passe
vers l'agroécologie une agriculture qui
réinstalle des jeunes en agriculture on
peut créer cent mille emplois dans
l'agriculture alors que vous avez raison
il ya cent mille emplois qui ont disparu
ces dernières années on peut respecter
l'environnement on peut et on a vu les
retient la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est quoi la souveraineté alimentaire
moi je suis surpris et vous savez de
manière rapide nous sommes en jeu est
rapide vous savez nous le premier
candidat écolo en 114 rené dumont
c'était un inconnu on a porté la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est quoi la
souveraineté alimentaire aujourd'hui
c'est en fait un
décider de notre modèle agricole et
notre modèle alimentaire ne pas être
dépendant notamment des firmes
et c'est une forme d'autonomie pas
l'indépendance je suis pas contre la fin
des échanges agricoles y compris on
exporte de très bons vins mecs pour
plein de choses tant mieux mais c'est la
souveraineté c'est quoi au fond c'est
par exemple s'affranchir des
importations de soja des amériques savez
la culture de soja c'est ce qui détruit
l'amazonie aujourd'hui et ce à accélérer
dramatiquement le dérèglement climatique
s'est arrêtée de dépendre des ags des
engrais azotés ça fait longtemps qu'on
se bat contre les engrais azotés qui
participe du dérèglement climatique
abba ou qu ils sont en train d'exploser
parce qu'on dépend du reste du monde
s'est arrêté de dépendre pour nos
marchés de la russie de la chine où on
essaye d'être en concurrence avec le
brésil où nos deux pays les brésiliens
seront toujours moins cher parce qu'on
veut payer nos paysans dignement et
qu'aujourd'hui ils n'arrivent plus à
être payés dignement donc notre
souveraineté alimentaire c'est justement
avoir des fermes qui construisent leur
autonomie savez c'est facile à un
élevage où par exemple les ruminants
pâture plutôt que d'être enfermé nourri
aux tourteaux de soja et ben c'est une
ferme qui va produire de la qualité qui
respecte ces animaux qui peut être
neutre en carbone et qui nous fournit
une alimentation de qualité donc moi le
le le et on va mettre les 13 milliards
au service de ça et moi je suis prêt à
mettre la dette des agriculteurs sur la
table pour que avec la caisse des dépôts
et des consignations on puisse reprendre
les dettes des agriculteurs parce que ce
qui les maintient dans le piège qui tue
l'agriculture française aujourd'hui
c'est l'endettement on leur a dit
culteurs bien celles
ci passent au bio js condition qu'ils
passent au bio mais bien sûr mais façon
il faut sortir du glyphosate
promesses non tenues par le président la
république il faut sortir des
néonicotinoïdes
renoncement du président de la
république pour à la fois des
agriculteurs ils ont dit que c'était
difficile à mesa certains agriculteurs
ja plein d'agriculteurs qui s'en passe à
un moment donné si vous voulez on a vu
dans ce quinquennat le président de la
république n'a jamais reçu les
associations de protection de la
biodiversité
il n'a cessé de recevoir le lobby de la
chasse il n'a jamais reçu les
agriculteurs qui ont fait la transition
et qui montre que ils vivent mieux en
polluant mois en respectant les animaux
en nous donnant une alimentation saine
et savoureuse il a toujours préféré le
lobby des pesticides ou lobby
l'agriculture industrielle il a toujours
préféré total et le nucléaire aux
énergies renouvelables et aux artisans
du bâtiment eh ben ça c'est un choix
politique sur lequel évidemment nous
reviendrons totalement on va passer aux
questions de mobilité de transport on
retrouve eric berger justement eric
berger avec notamment une question sur
la lgv oui en effet c'est un autre sujet
très important ici à toulouse et en
occitanie vous savez toulouse est une
des dernières grandes métropoles à ne
pas être connecté au réseau lgv le
réseau à grande vitesse et donc il ya ce
projet de lgv bordeaux toulouse qui
avance rapidement
le premier ministre a en effet annoncé
que 1 p 12 heures ben oui ils avancent
dans les faits il ya un plan de
financement qui a été validé cet objet d
faut rappeler qu'elle doit permettre de
gagner une heure sur le temps de trajet
entre toulouse et paris
grâce au train et puis de rendre le
train concurrentiel par rapport à
l'avion qui reste aujourd'hui
le moyen le plus rapide pour relier
toulouse à paris donc ma question est
très simple est ce que vous êtes
favorable ou non à cette lgv qui doit
normalement favoriser le train par
rapport à l'avion
alors favorisé le train par rapport à
l'avion c'est une évidence
le train c'est cinquante fois moins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre que
l'avion donc
nous voulons d'ailleurs investir
très substantiellement dans le train
train de personnes trains de
marchandises et trains de nuit le
problème qu'on a c'est que pendant des
années effectivement parce qu'il y avait
ce projet potentiel de lgv car longtemps
été mis remis au placard mais qui a été
ressortie par le président de région
rousset
donc on a sous investis sur les lignes
existantes
on a aujourd'hui un projet de lgv à 14
milliards d'euros 14 milliards d'euros
si on investit la moitié de ce budget
sur les rénovation des lignes existantes
le différentiel que monsieur
l'évoquent de 1h passade 20 minutes
c'est un choix de société
c'est un choix stopper sa priorité 1 ont
évidemment on rénove les lignes
existantes
mais cette méthode intelligente et
susan rice et ses doigts ce qui arrive
mais c'est sud ouest d'après la dépêche
sud-ouest voilà la région est concernée
très mobilisés très mobilisés sur ce
sujet ça permet de faire le rer
métropolitain tués s'est toujours
présenté comme ça si vous voulez on nous
présente toujours à mais oui bien sûr
les françaises et les français on ferme
les l'égard du quotidien on ferme les
lignes du quotidien on force les
françaises et les français à utiliser
leur voiture et avec l'explosion des
prix des carburants c'est la hausse
c'est la réduction du pouvoir d'achat
donc en fait des pertes pour nous
explique en fait oui bien sûr vos trains
du quotidien ce qui l'essentiel des
transports on va y penser mais d'abord
d'abord d'abord on va faire les axes
nord-sud pour une petite partie des
français mais moi j'utilise le tgv je
suis pas con côté j'avais ma question
c'est les priorités qu'on se donne et
nos priorités absolues aujourd'hui c'est
que les personnes qui veulent aller
bosser les personnes qui veulent aller
chez le médecin qui emmènent leurs
enfants truc puisse utiliser un train du
quotidien des transports collectifs du
quotidien plutôt que toujours fantasmer
la gueule la grande ligne quand c'est
pas nécessaire nous on soutient par
exemple la ligne lgv montpellier
perpignan c'est pas qu'on est contre les
lgv c'est qu'à un moment donné la
question c'est qu'est ce qui est
prioritaire pour les françaises et les
français et pour nous c'est les
transports du quotidien merci eric
berger merci beaucoup et on va passer
aux questions de fracture territoriale
et je vois l'alliance entre la dépêche
du midi et sidwell s'envoyer
plus il ya plus de concurrence mais mais
moi si vous voulez encore une fois la
question bien sûr qu'il faut désenclaver
tous les territoires mais franchement on
se bat tous les jours pour ça mais
regarder partout y compris qu'elles sont
des priorités des françaises et des
français justement va parler de ces
questions de fracture territoriale
absolument une autre priorité qui sont
qui est rare dans la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux
je prends un exemple de ma région le
centre val de loire quel plus grand
désert médical français le gouvernement
a annoncé récemment à six semaines de la
présidentielle
hemming qui tombe à pic qu'une seconde
je vous laisse juge je voulais j'assume
qu'une seconde fac de médecine verrait
le jour en l'occurrence à orléans est ce
que c'est le bon modèle est ce que vous
soutenez cette initiative du
gouvernement à écouter qu'ils faillent
formé beaucoup plus de médecins dans
notre pays c'est une évidence c'est une
évidence heureusement on est sorti du
numerus clausus mais aujourd'hui on
s'est pas donné les moyens de former
beaucoup plus la question c'est pas
simplement de stopper une limite haute à
la formation des médecins c'est de faire
en sorte que y vienne qui se forment et
que d'ici quelques années notamment 9 10
ans c'est ça la ccsa l'échéance on est
suffisamment de médecins dans notre pays
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
donc on fait en attendant de nouvelles
fac de médecine et bien sûr il faut il
faut renforcer les chaînes les chu aussi
parce que ça fonctionne avec la double
tutelle santé enseignement
supérieur
ça marche pas très bien on peut
améliorer les choses mais fort mais
c'est une évidence fort mais aussi
évidemment des infirmières des infirmes
et des aides-soignantes c'est l'ensemble
des personnels de santé et conservés
sont formés à ce qu'on oblige ses
médecins à s'installer alors on a
effectivement et vous l'avez dit on a
dans notre pays près de 8 millions de
personnes qui n'ont pas accès à un
médecin tout simplement ou dans des
conditions très difficiles qui sont
inacceptables dans un pays comme la
france café de la santé un joyau y
compris de la promesse républicaine donc
un
conventionnement sélectif ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'en fait vous êtes
vous êtes fort mais vous ne pouvez pas
aller sur une dans une région où ça sur
des objets sur dotées en matière de
médecin sauf remplacement d'un médecin
qui s'en va et deuxièmement
effectivement moi j'assume que on va
mettre en place à la fois
développer les maisons de santé des fois
ça marche bien des centres pluri
professionnelle
c'est un confort pour les médecins qui
veulent exercer ça permet les
remplacements parfois donc on va essayer
de développer tout ça mais moi j'assume
j'assume
dans mon projet jusqu'à ce qu'on ait
suffisamment de médecins il peut y avoir
obligation d'installation pour la
dernière année de médecine et pour les
deux prochaines années mais pour les
médecins dix ans d'études
jugé à s'installer je sais parfaitement
sauf que on peut pas se satisfaire
d'avoir une commune sur trois dans notre
pays keane qui est un désert médical que
les médecins hydro grande partie on a
besoin de médecins hospitaliers mais
c'est largement des professions
libérales mais qui sont payés par la
collectivité
quand vous êtes enseignant vous
choisissez pas où on va enseigner la
première fois quand vous êtes policier
mais dans votre région vous êtes formé
immédiatement vous est envoyé dans les
quartiers souvent les plus difficiles
donc un moment donné les médecins sont
aussi payés par la collectivité
on va on fera tout pour que les revenus
soient satisfaisants on fera tout pour
accompagner les familles mais à un
moment donné on peut pas avoir 8
millions de français qui n'ont pas accès
à un médecin l'autre sujet c'est la
question de la dépendance et c'est un
sujet qui va évidemment se poser de plus
en plus dans les années à venir question
de jefferson vous avez évoqué orpea tout
à l'heure yannick jadot qu'est ce que
vous dites aux familles qui ont des
proches dans les ehpad aujourd'hui qui
s'interroge sur le vieillissement
écoutez je pense que tout le monde
s'interroge sur le vieillissement et la
mort c'est c'est notre nature au fond
tout le monde s'interroge mandat
l'impression que les politiques
publiques n'ont pas pris ce problème à
vous avez parfaitement raison mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est un
problème personnel évidemment individuel
c'est un problème de société qui est
lourd la relation à la mort regarder y
compris pendant cette pandémie vous
savez combien il ya de morts de la
pandémie
non on n'en parle plus ce que je veux
dire c'est que pendant longtemps pendant
cette pandémie on nous a expliqué que le
r dewet supérieure ou inférieure à truc
on nous a sorti des chiffres que
personne ne comprenait mais parce qu'on
avait envie d'évacuer le nombre de morts
au quotidien parce que la mort c'est
terrifiant voilà c'est comme ça bon
et donc y compris la perte d'autonomie
est vu avec beaucoup de difficultés
parce que on n'est plus dans des des
fonctionnements de société où les
anciens est-ce que c'est ta maison a
pris vers issa sall n'est pas de priver
autre chose donc donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est pas un sujet facile
pour la société mais vous avez
parfaitement raison les gouvernements
ont toujours mis le sujet sous le tapis
où ils ont choisi une option c'est de
soutenir au fond le développement des
ehpad privé à but lucratif on sait que
ça a été largement le cas sous
gouvernement sarkozy ça s'est poursuivi
avec le quinquennat hollande et avec le
quinquennat macron
il y aura plus d pad privé à but
lucratif il y aura plus d pad privé à
but lucratif l'accord d'investissement
avec la chine pendant le génocide sur
les ouigours emmanuel macron défend les
ehpad privé à but lucratif
je dédie dans l'accord avec la russie ce
que je sais qu'il ya pas de surprise
dans ce coup là vous avez des cris
d'orfraie ou d'un seul coup on a
l'impression que dans l'espace sable
politique des coûts la situation des
ehpad non ils ont soutenu ce modèle de
spéculations sur la perte d'autonomie
dont consorts durera plus d'autorisation
des pâtes privé à but lucratif et
puisque je vais renforcer les droits de
succession sur les grandes fortunes qui
échappent très largement à l'impôt
aujourd'hui sur les successions ça fait
8 à 9 milliards qu'on mettra dans une
grande politique d'autonomie en
renforçant en améliorant la possibilité
de rester à la maison on sait combien
les aides à domicile sont maltraités
dans notre pays 6 à 700 euros de revenus
parfois pour des journées de 12 de 10 à
12 heures on met qu'on créera des lieux
intermédiaire avant les épaves ou des
lieux ouverts sur la société des lieux
partagez et puis on s'assurera que dans
nos ehpad on est en termes de personnel
un personnel pour un pensionnaire comme
ça existe dans des pays du nord ébats
avec ce financement ça nous permettra de
sortir de l'indignité ça nous permettra
de sortir de la spéculation sur la perte
d'autonomie et ça nous permettra de
respecter nos aînés comme il le mérite
yannick jadot raccourci de notre tour de
france on va aller à ajaccio retrouver
roger antech bonjour roger merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous roger de corse
matin yannick jadot vous étiez encore il
ya quelques semaines d'ailleurs très
clairement
positionnée sur les questions qui
concernent lille et roger à des
questions pour vous j'avais prévu de
vous interroger sur leurs factures
territoriale et l'insularité avec vous
une mémé l'actualité nous a rattrapés il
ya eu mercredi l'agression d'yvan
colonna à la maison centrale d'arles par
parent détenus anciens jihadistes et il
état d'extrême gravité dans lesquelles
se trouvent aujourd'hui ce militant
nationaliste condamné pour l'assassinât
du préfet erignac cette violence ne pose
pas seulement la question de la sécurité
dans les prisons françaises où les
conditions de détention dont les
terroristes islamistes notamment l
envoie l'un des sujets majeurs encore ce
qui fait d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans son
règlement unanimité politique celui du
rapprochement des prisonniers corses
dans une région de l'île vous êtes dans
votre visite encore se prononcer pour ce
rapprochement des prisonniers qui est
une application du droit mais que le
maintien au statut de détenu
particulièrement signalé maintien répété
par par le gouvernement notamment les
membres du conte du coin d'aurignac
empêche estimez-vous comme le président
de l'exécutif de corse gilles simeoni
que la responsabilité de l'état est
accablante de régression des banques aux
lônes avec ensemble at il des risques
d'embrasement que cela peut constituer
dans l'île en ce moment même moment vous
me parle un bateau transportant ferry
transportant des défauts renforts de
forces de l'ordre et empêcher lacoste et
dans le port d'ajaccio
vous avez parfaitement raison
c'est une situation absolument
dramatique
j'avais eu l'occasion de l'exprimer avec
l'ensemble des des élus des responsables
écologistes mais vous savez excepté plus
que c'était trans partisan 7,7 demande
du rapprochement qui est simplement
l'application de la loi qui est
simplement la loi rien que la loi toute
la loi et on nous a expliqué
qu'effectivement
le système
d ps était un système qui au fond est un
système de sécurité on voit que ça ne
l'est pas donc il faut évidemment que il
ya une enquête très forte moi je
souhaite qu'ils aient une commission
denquête à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
sujet pour savoir ce régime dps et
pourquoi finalement ça a bloqué le
rapprochement des prisonniers corses et
qu'on fasse toute la lumière sur ce qui
s'est passé mais je continuais dès
l'ouverture de la prochaine bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr j'ai soutenu vous
savez le rapprochement est ce qui est
dramatique c'est que
on a une situation politique est assez
unique en corse il ya eu un scrutin très
fort en soutien à la majorité actuelle
et avec un mandat de travailler à ce
qu'on appelle une autonomie de plein
exercice et de plein droit comment la
corse avec l'état français a la
possibilité de sortir d'une relation de
défiance
d'année d'année on avait la possibilité
le point d'entrée c'était le
rapprochement mais au delà ça c'est la
formulation de nouvelles compétences et
là encore il faut regretter que le
président de la république qui s'était
engagé auprès de gilles simeoni pour
travailler sur un renforcement de cette
autonomie n'est pas saisi l'occasion
d'un contexte politique en corse est
extrêmement favorable à cette discussion
là et si les français décident le
prochain quinquennat qui sera à la fois
le quinquennat présidentiel mais qui
sera aussi le mandat de la majorité en
place puis cette amende a encore une
fois qui permet de sortir d'une relation
de défiance que n'a pas saisi le
président de la république alors que la
majorité en corse lui tendez la main et
un dernier mot rapidement rejet
justement j'avais l'intention de
demander à tout ce qui m'était derrière
l'expression autonomie de plein droit de
plein exercice notamment en matière de
dévolution de l'exercice des compétences
territoriales et plus largement c'est de
sa conception d'une décentralisation des
compétences et des pouvoirs qui
pourraient s'appliquer à d'autres
territoires alors la demande vous savez
que ce ce statut d'autonomie de plein
droit et de plein exercice d'ailleurs a
été soutenu par régions de france par
l'ensemble des régions qui sont des
invités qui soutiennent cette idée d'une
autonomie plus forte encore plus de
compétences mais qui renvoie aussi à
l'échec de toutes les derniers processus
de décentralisation
ce qu'a fait françois hollande au fond
est une catastrophe c'est une
catastrophe dans toutes les régions il
ya le on peut pourrait parler de l'est
ce qu'on pourrait parler de toutes les
régions jeudi renouvelle aquitaine enfin
franchement c'est une caricature fuir
cette région est ingérable je veux dire
par sa part la multiplicité l'étendue la
diversité bien sûr c'est ridicule donc
on marche au fond tout ça tout ça ne ne
fonctionne pas donc il faut renforcer il
faut une nouvelle phase de
décentralisation pour la corse c'est
clairement comment la collectivité a les
moyens de garantir la continuité
territoriale
c'est la question des compagnies
aériennes c'est la question des
compagnies maritimes sait comment il
peut y avoir particulièrement en corse
mais on sait que ça se pose maintenant
bretagne ailleurs la question de la
spéculation foncière qui auront en train
de retirer les capacités d'habiter aux
habitants qu'ils sont là 365 jours sur
c'est la question des déchets c'est la
question de la gestion du tourisme
dont il faut encore une fois et ça sera
la négociation engagée dans le prochain
quinquennat définir ce qu'est cette
autonomie mais si vous laissiez eu
autant d'abstention
aux départementales et aux régionales
c'est parce que en fait plus personne ne
comprend rien à ce que sont les
compétences des départements des régions
et on parle pas des des comités de des
communautés commune donc au fond il faut
remettre de la transparence il faut
remettre de la simplicité dans la
gestion de nos collectivités qui sont
pour nous
les leviers essentiels de la
reconstruction de notre pays mais on va
remercier argent tech merci roger
évidemment on suivra avec vous les
derniers développements sur l'île de
beauté dans cette émission vous serez
avec nous c'est prochains jours vous
parliez du grand test yannick jadot on
va y aller dernière étape de notre tour
de france des régions va à strasbourg on
retrouve olivier claude un des dernières
nouvelles d'alsace est aboli les
bons jours yannick jadot strasbourg
alsace qui aime tellement la région
venteuse est tellement amoureux de la
région gros test
vous faites allusion à la consultation
organisée par le président de la
collectivité
écoutez moi je laisse par principe je
contiens référendum local je laisse
les alsaciennes et les alsaciens ont
décidé
de toute façon ça fait longtemps que
l'alsace réfléchit à à son statut
travail sur son statut sur sa
spécificité qui n'est pas une
spécificité de repli c'est ça qui est
toujours important mais les questions
sur la zone zone à faible émission vous
à olivier
oui tout à fait strasbourg c'est une
ville que vous connaissez bien puisque
vous êtes député européen le parlement
siège il a dirigé par une mairie cologie
stéphane par des clients et les
écologistes dirige également
l'agglomération l'eurométropole dans les
tons l'exécutif a vécu des moments
difficiles
l'an dernier quand il a été question de
préparer la mise en oeuvre de la zone à
faible émission leur métropole sous
l'impulsion des écologistes a décidé
d'aller plus loin que la loi qui
maillent résilience pour d'ores et déjà
prévoir l'interdiction de tous les
véhicules diesel d'ici 2028 peu voire
plus tôt si possible ce qui suscite
beaucoup de craintes dans la population
parmi les automobilistes qui dès lors
parler écologie punitive qu'est ce que
vous dites à ces automobilistes qui
craignent de ne pas d'avoir les moyens
de changer de voiture et finalement qui
craignent de ne pas pouvoir s'adapter
ce qui est punitif dans cette affaire ce
n'est pas l'écologie ce qui est punitif
c'est que dans notre pays selon les
différentes estimations on est entre
50000 et cent mille morts par an liés à
la pollution de l'air c'est plus que le
tabac c'est plus que l'alcool donc c'est
une catastrophe sanitaire la pollution
de l'air donc c'est ça qui est punitif
aujourd'hui la question c'est comment on
fait en sorte que à strasbourg comme
ailleurs nos enfants puissent jouer dans
les cours que il n'est pas une explosion
des maladies chroniques liées à la
pollution de l'air d asthme chez les
enfants
donc c'est ça l'enjeu c'est de ça dont
on doit partir qu'est ce que veut faire
la maire de strasbourg et kehl et son
principal chantier aujourd'hui c'est le
développement de toutes les mobilités
qui offriront une alternative aux
personnes qui ont aujourd'hui une
automobile moi je viens de picardie
dans les hauts de france
je sais qu'on peut avoir besoin d'une
voiture évidemment je suis où je suis né
où je vais on a besoin d'une voiture
donc c'est comment on construit la
possibilité d'avoir des alternatives en
matière de transports collectifs
bus tram dans d'autres villes s'appelle
des métros
oui mais là on est pas on n'est pas
demain c'est pas demain que ça
s'applique donc
les lots strasbourg et de ce point de
vue là modèle en cycle c'est curieux
envoi sécurisé et puis comment quand on
a absolument besoin d'une voiture essais
concernent encore une majorité de
français on a accès à une automobile qui
n'est pas une un véhicule diesel donc
c'est tout les prix moi je veut
multiplier par deux les prime à la
conversion automobile c'est y compris
sur des véhicules d'occasion qui ne sont
pas des véhicules diesel évidemment
c'est suffit pour ces français on prend
l'exemple à qui on demande de changer de
véhicule ou et met en avant on a bien
parlé de 2028 on a parlé de 2028 il faut
quand même qu'on ne peut pas en
permanence ne pas anticiper les
impératifs et les défis auxquels danlos
confrontés parce qu'à chaque fois sinon
c'est la catastrophe à chaque fois c'est
difficile pour les françaises et les
français en 2000 à partir de d'ici cinq
ans selon les toutes les études les
véhicules électriques seront à paris
était pris avec les véhicules thermiques
c'est aujourd'hui sont plus chères
incontestablement mais un peu comme les
énergies renouvelables les prix sont en
train de baisser donc on sera pas été
pris à l'achat et évidemment ça coûte
beaucoup moins cher à la maintenance et
en termes de 2,2 d'énergie donc il faut
accompagner toutes ces grandes
transitions mais ce qu'on dit est ce que
portent les écologistes dans toutes les
villes où nous assumons cette
responsabilité de santé c'est on
accompagne on accompagne on accompagne
on ne ferme pas l'accès à aux classes
populaires aux personnes qui ont
absolument besoin de véhicules sans
avoir créé l'alternative ses principes
on remercie olivier
dans ces crises olivier vous aviez une
autre question mais malheureusement le
temps file merci beaucoup elysées
d'avoir été avec nous il y ait des
dernières nouvelles d'alsace quelques
questions sur votre campagne pour
terminer yannick jadot puisqu'on a
appris parce que la campagne mais sur
votre campagne politique on a beaucoup
parlé des sujets de fond vous le regard
c'est ça c'est ça la politique on
accueille six ans qui intéresse les
français c'est ça qu'ils attendent je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu
cette émission mais quand même on a
appris hier que sandrine rousseau avait
été exclu de votre équipe de campagne
c'était la finaliste de la primaire des
écologistes qu'est ce qui s'est passé
écoutez vous avez bien vu que sandrine
rousseau depuis des semaines depuis la
primaire
mendo de campagne que la campagne
présidentielle avec avec des positions
législatives qui pourraient coûter il ya
évidemment la question des législatives
on n'entend qu'eux elle veut conquérir
le parti bon tout ça n'est pas
compatible avec la loyauté
la ligne politique
selon vous de la campagne et donc on en
tire moi je prends acte
d'une énième de d'énièmes prise de
position qui ne sont pas celles de la
campagne une campagne de lutte lui
présidentielle dans la situation de
notre pays aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose de très sérieux les egos versèrent
pour vous aujourd'hui son âne aux enjeux
pour une adversaire simplement s'il veut
prendre le parti qui a la double
ambition rim et ça c'est pas la campagne
présidentielle
respecter les règles de la primaire ce
n'était pas un soutien pour vous écouter
à partir du moment où vos prises de
position parasites la campagne des
écologistes savez les écologistes se
sont rassemblés pour cette campagne
présidentielle on doit attendre
éternellement en 2022 ce qui va se jouer
c'est est ce qu'on est capable est ce
que notre pays se met en situation de
gagner la bataille du climat ou bas est
ce qu'on gagne la bataille de la vie et
du vivant ou pas elles sont un hôpital
français mais selon à l'innovation
économique industrielle et la justice
sociale que nous portons si des
personnes poursuivre d'autres objectifs
c'est pas mon sujet mais ça peut mettre
la campagne fressoz mais je sais pas
voulu pour vous lui poserez mais
maintenant on est aujourd'hui elle
pourra plus représenté la campagne des
écologistes pour un pâle elle ne pourra
plus parler au nom des écologistes dans
cette campagne c'est une forme de
clarification après des semaines
est-ce que c'était pas gênant pour vous
quelles qu'elles portent votre part si
si quand je fais des entretiens des
interviews on me dit oui mais sandrine
rousseau ait pas d'accord oui c'est pas
vous savez vous avez tous nous voulait
pour nous le mouvement écologiste tout
le mouvement écologiste est mobilisé par
rapport à ces urgences climatiques
sociale ou jamais les écologistes n'ont
été aussi préparé jamais non si travail
et la crédibilité de leurs solutions on
peut pas avoir une campagne qui est
parasité par des avis divergents ou
différents part au fond des prises de
position des prises de position des noms
parce que vous voyez n'est jamais seul
jamais les écologistes ont été aussi
préparé jamais été aussi disciplinés et
ils font valoir la discipline
aujourd'hui j'ai pris la décision de
faire valoir la discipline pour que le
projet prit la division qui est non mais
c'est pas moi qui divise nous on joue
collectif
les gens qui à un moment donné considère
que c'est leur prise de position
personnelle leur avenir personnel qui
doit prédominer ceux qui prennent là là
là au fond qui prennent des décisions de
se sortir du collectif est là encore il
avait là sur europe écologie
moi je parle pas d'europe écologie les
verts moi je suis le candidat des
écologistes à l'élection présidentielle
laurent une question sur christiane
taubira j'en ai toute discussion et
christiane taubira côté 1 nulle part non
mais nulle part oui et je pense qu'il ya
dans lesquelles vous soutiennent il ya
une profonde il ya une profonde
déception chez christiane évidemment
après cette campagne compliquée
c'est mal parti dans une alliance qua
non j'en sais rien c'est à elle de
décider seuls de décider je précise bien
dans les prochains jours qui arrivent à
écouter
vous souhaitez les valeurs qu'elle
défend les positions qu'elle a prise sur
l'ukraine en soutien à la résistance
ukrainienne en pour en affirmant comme
nous affirmons que il faut sortir de
toutes les complaisances vis-à-vis de
vladimir poutine parce qu'il est quand
même un paquet de candidats qui
aujourd'hui essaye au fonds de se
refaire la cerise en nous expliquant
nous expliquant en nous faisant des
grandes leçons des géopolitique mais au
fond pour dire quoi comme vladimir
poutine l'ukraine appartient à la russie
que au fond
ou jean luc mélenchon parle comme bailly
maire poutine aujourd'hui non je dis pas
ça mais reconnaissez que il a soutenu
l'annexion de la crimée en 2014 il a
justifié les bombardements des
populations civiles en syrie ça n'est
pas ma position sur la démocratie il n'a
pas voté
la reconnaissance du génocide
sur les ouigours bon si vous ou moi la
démocratie c'est à paris c'est à kiev
c'est à moscou et c'est aussi pour
l'ennemi gour simplement voilà et puis
moi je pense que l'union européenne est
un des outils essentiels
essentiel pour défendre notre projet de
société une france forte dans une europe
puissante donc voilà on a des
divergences je connais les convictions
de christiane taubira après ça reste son
choix on verra et on suivra tout ça
merci beaucoup merci et merci d'avoir
été notre invité pour cette émission
spéciale merci florent regarde à une
république du centre masques et passent
plus que dix jours c'est à la une de
votre journal qu'elle a une de sud ouest
j'ai personnes emmanuel macron président
et candidat merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité yannick jadot
[Musique]